st-amour une commune située en saône et
loire
mais c'est aussi un grand cru beaujolais
à part entière il est né en fait en 1945
les français est encore en pleines
restrictions pour élever ce vignoble
haut rang ces grandes appellations
d'origine contrôlée les viticulteurs du
coin ont su mettre en valeur leur
terroir
on a ici la vigne dans la peau et quel
que soit le temps le vigneron soigne
coupe surveille son vignoble
je suis ici monsieur plus anciens
trente ans que je suis à mon compte dans
la literie six mois six à huit et on n'a
toujours fait ça quand on j'ai commencé
avec un cheval et ils cherchent
maintenant la tôle ondulée charrues est
dense et un tracteur s'est laissé
nettement différent alors voilà pour la
vigne la taille est à peu près à peu
près sensiblement la même façon il est
obligé quand même avec le père passionné
détracteurs entre elles pour voir des
cèpes 6e trop large
st-amour compte à l'heure actuelle 4 155
habitants et une soixantaine d'ex
ploitation la récolte atteint près de
quinze mille hectolitres
à travers ces images qui peuvent
paraître un peu rétro on a su grandir
ici on exporte près de 50% de la
production
ce village vie du vin et c'est sa chance
c'est sachant si ce village n'avait pas
eu le vin que ce soit pour son économie
pour ses habitants pour l'ambiance de ce
village ce sera un village morts on n'a
que que cette réussite c'est le vin
l'appellation qui est venu en 45 a
permis de donner une autre image du
village une autre a donné quelque chose
de plus aux vignerons le vin à fixer les
jeunes par cet espoir si vous voulez
faire porter l'appellation et cet amour
de ce métier de vigneron à donner aux
enfants envie de vivre de ce 26
splendide et vous voyez comment le
saint-amour est un vin qui peut se
garder très longtemps lors qu'on est
toujours que le beaujolais est un vin à
boire jeunes et là on a la preuve qu'on
se trompe dans les grandes années il
faut garder ces bouteilles pour pour les
bois entre nous entre amis on est sur
des bouteilles de collection née sur une
sur des bouteilles d'exception
l'élargissement de la communauté
européenne n'est pas ressenti ici comme
un réel danger
il est vrai que le saint-amour dernier
des neuf grands crus du beaujolais
représente une valeur sûre du négoce
actuelle la vente de beaujolais primeur
qui représente je crois la moitié de la
récolte
quelque chose prêt est un phénomène
social très important qui se développe
de plus en plus où tout le monde est
dépassé ne prenons pas l'exemple du
beaujolais
c'est un exemple trop facile à suivre on
crée un vin on n'a pas le temps de les
lever et ça y est il est déjà vendu
la saint vincent patron des vignerons a
donc été l'occasion idéale pour sortir
quelques vieilles bouteilles déguster
selon la tradition les crues de l'année
ont été à nouveau apprécié chez les
viticulteurs on a décidément le sens de
la fête